[Musique]
comment réussir notre transition
énergétique alors que les métaux
stratégiques vont être amenées à manquer
bonjour Guillaume Pitron bonjour David
Jacquot cet auteur de la guerre des
métaux rares aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent d'abord de quoi parle-t-on
pardon déjà de poser un peu le décor les
métaux stratégiques c'est vrai qu'ils
sont partout et pourtant on les connaît
pas bien il y a pas de voiture
électrique il y a pas d'éolienne il n'y
a pas de panneaux solaires sans eux
c'est clair ça en fait des métaux
stratégiques ce sont des métaux qui sont
indispensables pour une industrie
considérée comme stratégie de par un
État en France nos industries
stratégiques c'est notamment la
l'industrie automobile et donc les
métaux qui servent à fabriquer les
voitures électriques sont des métaux qui
sont éminemment stratégiques on parle du
lithium on parle également du cuivre on
parle du cobalt du nickel d'un minerai
qui s'appelle le graphite tous ces
métaux sont ils vont devenir de plus en
plus importants on ne pourra pas on ne
peut pas d'ores et déjà on ne pourra pas
faire de transition énergétique que sans
eux juste un chiffre pour bien
imprimer cette idée
internationale de l'énergie nous dit que
dans les 20 ans qui viennent dans 20 ans
notre consommation de lithium dans le
monde sera 42 fois supérieur à ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui lithium qui sert
qui va servir majoritairement pour les
batteries des véhicules électriques
voilà et donc c'est métaux sont rares
certains sont rares d'autres sont
abondants il faut s'y retrouver un petit
peu aussi là-dedans les métaux abondants
cuivre fer aluminium zinc et puis des
maisons stratégiques mais ils sont pas
rares tout à fait ils sont stratégiques
mes parents en tout cas le cuivre peut
être considéré comme un métal éminemment
stratégique parce qu'il en faut pour les
voitures électriques et puis après vous
avez des métaux plus rares que les
métaux abondants parce que 1000 fois
plus rares mille fois plus rare dans les
Corses terrestres que les grands métaux
donc ça veut dire qu'ils sont très
dilués et donc on peut les considérer
comme rares alors naturellement on en
trouve jusqu'au fond désocéans de ces
métaux comme les terres rares ou le
cobalt donc ils sont rares et rares à la
fois mais l'industrie aime bien les
qualifier de rares parce que plus dilué
et donc il faut bien les chercher à un
coût écologique très élevé pardon c'est
quoi les terres rares alors les terres
rares c'est une classe de rares qui se
subdivise en 15 métaux dont le néodyme
qui est important pour les aimants qui
font fonctionner les moteurs de la
plupart de nos voitures électriques mais
vous avez également du néodyme dans
votre téléphone portable il fait vibrer
votre téléphone portable donc les terres
c'est une sous-catégorie encore les
demandes justement pour ces métaux
stratégiques vont exploser ça on a bien
compris dans les prochaines années
décennies et ce qu'on va en manquer
c'est ça le sujet le risque il est là et
lesquels métaux stratégiques rares
critiques sont les plus concernés alors
d'abord il faut savoir qu'il y a pas de
limite géologique il y a des limites
géologiques mais il y a pas de rareté
géologiques comme je vous l'ai dit de
ces métaux on peut en trouver jusqu'au
fond des océans et pourquoi pas sur la
crête des astéroïdes donc sur le papier
il y a tout ce qu'on veut le problème
c'est à quel coût est-ce qu'on va aller
les extraire la teneur des gisements
baisse donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
creuser toujours plus profondément
généré toujours plus de rebut il faut
consommer davantage d'électricité pour
extraire la même quantité de matière il
faut plus d'eau pour aller raffiner la
même quantité de matière avec un coût
écologique plus élevé or les populations
locales sont pas forcément d'accord et
ça c'est un goût étranglement
extrêmement important le politique finit
par hésiter et voir si oppose et donc en
fait vous avez un ensemble de critères
qui en fait font que le métal pourrait
ne pas être extrait suffisamment par
rapport à la demande donc générer des
situations de pénurie non pas parce
qu'il est encore une fois rare dans les
corps terrestres mais parce que les
coûts d'extraction sont-elles et les
enjeux que finalement on se dit on
préfère s'en passer et c'est là le
risque est-ce que ce sont toujours des
pays fréquentables ou pas alors qui
produit ces métaux stratégiques alors
l'Australie est un pays tout à fait
fréquentable le Chili est un pays
fréquentable le problème c'est qu'une
partie de la production de ces pays est
rachetée par des entreprises chinoises
et ces entreprises chinoises exportent
importent le minerai jusque sur le
territoire chinois et c'est en Chine qui
va être affiné donc c'est à dire qu'il
va être affiné en utilisant une
électricité raffinée ça veut dire
raffiné c'est-à-dire qu'il va être
transformé en produits finis prêt à être
utilisé dans les cellules des batteries
or l'électricité qui permet sera finage
c'est une électricité qui vient du
charbon majoritairement Chine donc vous
avez paradoxe des énergies back carbone
et demain des voitures bas carbone qui
en fait qui en fait pour pour la
fabrication desquelles il a fallu
émettre du CO2 donc est-ce que c'est
fréquentable d'aller acheter du minerai
en Chine non pas vraiment est-ce que
c'est fréquentable d'aller acheter du
métal en Chine non donc l'enjeu demain
ça va être mais comment est-ce qu'on se
passe de la Chine y compris des
batteries chinoises parce qu'on achète
carrément les batteries au chinois et
comment on extrait de ça de manière
propre responsable et responsable alors
chez nous voilà donc propre on met ce
terme de côté ça n'arrivera jamais
interdit notre vocabulaire jusqu'à la
fin des temps d'accord sur la même
stratégie ne fera jamais de mine propre
c'est un mythe mais on fera pas non plus
germinal et la psyché française autour
des moments de côté l'ami du futur sera
entre les deux et ce sera une mine que
l'on peut qualifier de responsable
c'est-à-dire que nous allons extraire le
minerai selon des critères et des normes
sociales environnementales qui seront
plus respectueuses que ce qu'on a pu
faire par le passé et puis respectueuse
que ce que font les chinois et donc
c'est là cette sur cette fine ligne de
crête que on doit pouvoir relancer une
industrie minière notamment en Europe
pour pouvoir avoir nos propres
approvisionnements à un coût écologique
moindre ça se joue donc à l'échelle
nationale et surtout européenne on sait
que la Commission européenne l'Europe
est en train de bouger pour retrouver un
peu de souveraineté en la matière ça
passe déjà peut-être par changer nos
fournisseurs tout à fait changer un
petit peu la cartographie je sais pas
quels sont les pays qui pourraient être
visés le Canada notamment oui absolument
à rendu visite à son homologue Justine
Trudeau il a été question durant cette
visite officielle au Canada
d'approvisionnement en nickel on cobalt
en lithium par les Canadiens pour les
besoins de Volkswagen
Ursula funderleion a également évoqué
des partenariats commerciaux avec des
pays producteurs de ces minerais comme
l'Australie comme le Chili comme le
Mexique donc la palette de notre diplôme
de nos actions de nos de les cordes que
nous avons à notre arc inclut également
ce que pour appeler une nouvelle
diplomatie minérale une diplomatie
minérale après la diplomatie pétrolière
la diplomatie minérale il y a une
nouvelle géopolitique du verre de la
transition énergétique du Green Deal qui
est en train de se mettre en place mais
ces pays d'adidjacos qui ont voulu nous
vendre leur matière première je veux
dire vous le voulez avoir vous produire
avec un coût écologique certains le
minerai à un neurones kilo et le vendre
à des pays européens on voulait pas du
tout ça les états producteurs veulent
soit taxer fortement le produit soit
remonter la chaîne de valeur
c'est-à-dire en fait non pas vendre le
minerai ou le métal mais vendre les
batteries de voitures électriques et
pourquoi pas les voitures électriques
même demain
et ils ne veulent pas être des états
miniers et ils veulent être des
électro-états il y a eu des on peut
aller trop
états donc il faut regarder notre
sous-sol chez nous aussi pas seulement
voir les fournisseurs mais voir comment
on dit qu'on produira jamais 100% nous
on sera jamais autosuffisant la
souveraineté pure
chimiquement pur n'existe pas mais une
forme de souveraineté existe la
souveraineté elle passe en particulier
par des alliances avec des avec des pays
producteurs donc avec qui allons nous
créer des liens d'interdépendance elle
passe par le recyclage on va pouvoir
davantage recycler parce qu'on va avoir
de plus en plus de batterie de voiture
recyclées tandis ou dans 15 ans et comme
ça ce sera une source de matière
première et puis après reste la partie
production sur notre sol on produira pas
tout par exemple je peux vous dire qu'on
produira pas assez de terre rare par
rapport à nos besoins pas cette coballe
par rapport à nos besoins on pourra pas
tout produire mais on peut produire une
partie on pourra produire une grande
partie du lithium dont nous avons besoin
et retrouver un peu de souveraineté et
puis la question ultime c'est ce qu'on
va réussir le pari de sécuriser
justement ces approvisionnements en
métaux stratégique pour réussir notre
transition énergétique on sait jouable
c'est une course qui est gagnée ou plus
certains diront perdus d'avance alors
d'abord on part très en retard parce que
les Chinois ont compris 20 ans avant
nous que ces matières premières allaient
devenir le nouveau pétrole dès que ça
l'aurait dit en 1992 et cela
foundialayan l'a dit en 2022 donc il
s'est passé 30 ans depuis en revanche on
peut rattraper notre retard et on
remarque que les Européens mais surtout
les Américains pour des raisons de
sécurité nationale parce que ces
ressources certes dans leur industrie de
défense ils ont pas du tout envie de
dépendre des Chinois pour faire voler
leur F35 l'équivalent de notre rafale et
bien accélère donc il y a un rattrapage
qui est en train de se faire serons-nous
souverains à 100% non il y aura des
interdépendances demain avec d'autres
pays il va falloir choisir ses nouveaux
alliés ce sera peut-être plus l'Arabie
Saoudite ce sera l'Indonésie ce sera
l'Australie ce sera le Chili ce sera la
Bolivie ce sera le Mexique et peut-être
d'autres pays la souveraineté relative
pour autant sera une souveraineté qui
sera la résultante de l'agrégation de
toutes ces solutions là encore une fois
on part avec du retard voilà merci
Guillaume pitro merci je rappelle votre
livre La guerre des métaux rares aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent merci à
vous
[Musique]